[Music]
[Music]
so I see I think everybody is here so I
thought maybe we start my name is Slava
gurevich and my email is on the board
which conveniently has my first name in
it the purpose of David Mindell who is a
principal investigator on this project
is speaking today on the National Public
Radio Science Friday program so I'm not
sure if you'll be here sandy brown with
research assistant and who has been in
contact with all of you it's currently
New Zealand
and he couldn't make it back because of
the recent tragic events I think this
events kind of make us think that maybe
we should appreciate every day of the
our lives that we have try to do as much
work as we can today I will say a few
words about the overall project for the
sake of Jim Miller and our tailor who
were not here at the first meeting the
project is called history of recent
science and technology on the web and
its goal is to develop some tools that
would enable veteran scientists and
engineers to participate in writing the
history of their particular discipline
in the projects so our role as
historians here is just be your helpers
to offer you some tools and to listen to
you what you would like to have in terms
of support and logistics that would
allow you to contribute to writing
history there are different formats for
using the web in this way some people
prefer using web forums our email lists
things like that
David David Mindell has suggested that
we would have these live meetings where
people would exchange their memories and
discuss some some of the historical
issues then we would have these meetings
transcribed and put transcripts on the
web where everybody could read them and
comment
on them we also are planning to put or
actually already doing it to put some
archival documents up on the web where
you could read it again you could write
comments on particular documents on
parts of it which also be posted on the
web so people after that could come and
see your compost your comments and the
original document and maybe write some
other comments so these are the kind of
things that we that we are thinking
about if you would think that some other
forms like discussion list would be
helpful please let us know and we'll try
that I don't know if anybody of you took
a look at at the website which is HRSD
stands for history in science and
technology doesn't have any www so this
is the overall project which includes
five sub projects one of which is Apollo
guidance computer while its molecular
evolution theory one is bioinformatics
and a couple of others in different
fields people try different approaches
we'll see what works in our case so far
we had one meeting last month and I
already have a transcript of it and as
far as I know it's been circulated
somewhat and people wrote some
corrections and we are planning to put
it up on the web
shortly within the next couple of weeks
and where you will all be able to see it
and comment on it I should mention that
this website is kind of working tool so
it has two layers on it one is public
what everybody can see and one is a
working area where only members of our
group can see and so when you put your
comment on the web only members of our
group would be able to see it at the
moment so because we would like to have
it some kind of place where we would be
able to discuss our views freely and you
know have some debate and then we would
decide what extent we would open it up
to the public so at the first meeting we
generally I just think it's for the
weather for the sake of the Jim Miller
and or Taylor who we're not there we
generally had an introduction when
people talked a little bit about their
role in in the development of software
for the Apollo guidance computer and and
we some of the general topics came up
what we would like generally to do is to
focus on a few important issues in this
project that would really that really
made that projects are salient and
significant issues that first of all
allowed that that enormous enterprise to
be accomplished successfully so as Fred
Martin I think put it last time if it
had to do this program today in the
manner it which programs are done today
I don't think the program could have
ever been done I don't think that the
amount of paper generated the meetings
abuse the number of people involved I
don't think the program would have ever
gotten off the ground that's very
interesting comment that that suggests
that the the way the project was done
back in the in the 60s was kind of
unique and we try to recreate that
uniqueness and that reason your own
remaining senses as participants are
inviolable that something that documents
cannot tell us so I would I would ask
you to bring up as much as you can these
elements of of uniqueness of something
that distinguish that particular project
and you work on it from from other
things if you could compare it
particularly with other things that you
encountered in other times in other
places or organizations and we'll draw
explicit comparisons that would help us
to to determine some distinguishing
features that would be particularly
helpful another thing that we would like
to do is to avoid writing kind of linear
history when basically what we often can
see there are always some points where
different decisions could be made they
were debates when you know there was
some role it's not taken someplace that
they had to go back and then go back so
we'd like to recreate that rather
complex roadmap instead of just
sequence of solutions that we eventually
found their way in the eventual product
so we'd like to have that sense of
debate of controversy what what exactly
was upon points of contention
different points of the project which
design decisions or organizational
decisions were particularly important
and debated at that time so that that
that history would be alive rather than
sequence of facts if you think that came
up in terms of topics that that we
discussed last time or the issue of the
separation the degree to which the
automatic and manual systems must be
combined in the guidance of the night
prayer of the spacecraft and as far as I
can see in in this discussion mostly the
issue of trust in the end electronic
equipment came up and the essence isn't
really trusted so the automatic side had
to be justified somehow while in the
Soviet program curiously and I should
mention that I'm actually working on the
Russian side on this story and the
Soviet problem was is the issue was what
extent we can draw the humans the over
that issue so somehow Soviets had a
greater belief in automatic systems in
their reliability and they thought that
humans was a weakest link so I'd like to
you know kind of friend that ish a
little bit around this this question
maybe these issues came up in your
project as well but you simply didn't
mention it so that would be interesting
I don't think is man-machine interface
to what extent the astronauts had an
input into the way they wanted to
interact with the computer what extent
computer designers had had si the role
of warning systems what extent computer
was allowed to
- let the astronaut know that that's
something that something that astronaut
is doing is not really right the the
issue of memory constraints and speed
constraint that that really put a limit
on on these kind of wake up and warning
systems also series of implementation
meetings are was mentioned and and the
issue of disciplining the software
program introducing all sorts of
measures that that kind of streamline
that process and made it manageable from
the NASA point of view and I would like
to maybe if you could say a few words
about the way that was done how it was
accepted what consequence did it have
and a little bit more detail on that and
lastly is a question of openness of the
whole project again there is a starting
a startling contrast with the Soviet
program which as you know was all
classified and run under the military
umbrella while the Apollo project was
open and some of the participants in the
last meeting stressed that it had a very
important role and I really want to push
you a little bit on that and see whether
this openness actually maybe post some
problems for you in terms of interacting
with military people maybe military
people didn't want to tell you something
because they knew that your project was
open or I'm just speculating about that
maybe it was no problem at all so maybe
you could say a few words about that so
today's meeting I would suggest to start
by asking Jim Miller and Taylor will not
hear the first time - oh yeah like a
smile I'm sorry to introduce themselves
and talk a little bit about you're all
in
Apollo guidance computer story and then
we would go around the table and have
people talking about the issues that was
Alex okay I think I started the I joined
the lab in 63 and back mmm for the
second time for the second time dan was
one who winkled me out of England to
come home at the star the Apollo program
I came as a physics graduate I knew
nothing about computers analog or
digital I need nothing about programming
and one of my observations actually it
has to do that because one of the
successes here I mean I know when
Margaret joined she'd know anything
about inertial navigation systems I hope
I'm not putting words in your mouth
and yet we grew this knowledge to the
extent that we needed to understand it
to control it the right programs that
control it to me that was always amazing
that so few people relatively
inexperienced in those in the subject
that we were dealing they were just
smart people managed to acquire enough
information from the vast array of
resources around us in the lab to not be
blocked by you know a wall of ignorance
I can't move because I don't know you
wouldn't found out you talk to people
and there weren't very many people that
you needed to do that was to me one of
the strengths of that program was the
few people that were working we was came
to the conclusion then and I talked
about this in the early days at the
optimum size of a software group
producing complicated suffer like this
was about five or six because during
some of the stressful period we were
really turning stuff out there were
little knots of five or six people that
really put the foundations to this one
of my roles when I began to feel my way
around that I can remember in my memory
release Thunder come apart at the edges
was to integrate some of these areas
there was a launch area that was a rien
tree area on that
there was a powered flight area who are
investigating the you know some of the
technical problems in these various
areas I had to stick these together in
order to achieve our first guided flight
which I still have pictures and stuff on
which we knew as Apollo 202 is to
manufacture the glue and just make stuff
up the integrated the astronauts actions
the powered flight equations track the
launch which we didn't control so when
the time we took over we knew where we
were and how fast we're going and so
forth then we talked about the
mid-course stuff which was a whole
nother ballgame which I knew absolutely
nothing often even at the end of program
I I didn't understand it very well so my
role is to knit some of these pieces
together and my memory is dim but it was
a heck of a lot of hard work long hours
stuff didn't work stuff we made up as we
went along didn't work but in the end it
all didn't work if I remember rightly
that first flight landed remarkably
close to its objective in the Pacific
being late late for lunch because I
wouldn't let you go and you're dying a
punker you remember a few of those right
I can ramble on but I think to meet a
amazing thing about this looking back
was the quality of the people the
fewness of the people the immense
support that you got from all the
reasons that were arrayed around you the
openness I guess is what you were
referring to before we ourselves at
least that's what I felt were the only
blocks you know because of ignorance but
we overcame that as we went along and it
made it work
the ups well just shut up at that point
I'd like to hear what some of the other
people
j-man not sure exactly how much of what
to cover but we covered her some things
briefly about how I got there and what I
did I evaded the draft during the Korean
War by going off to graduate school and
staying in college got a master's degree
in electrical engineering and that was
as long as I could postpone being in the
service and I entered the service in
1956 Air Force and was assigned to a
place called Cape Canaveral's or
something I never heard of it
and John Daley you read the news maybe
hadn't heard of it either and that's how
he pronounced it but within a week or
two of being there I was out of the Cape
and watched the Redstone
launched at night and I was completely
rocketry and guiding the things and
stayed in the service a couple years and
came up to MIT to get a doctorate in in
program doctor a program called
instrumentation which was a combination
of academic disciplines
multi-departmental I started writing
code for computers in 57 or something we
had a digital computer down down there
and eventually I got into programming it
for whatever reason and writing my
doctoral thesis I got into both
celestial mechanics because I wrote a
comment on the guidance of a one pound
thrust rocket vehicle from Earth orbit
to lunar orbit thousand-pound vehicle
with that one
takes a long time to build up the energy
you need to get out but in the process I
learned a lot about celestial mechanics
of trajectories and about writing code
for computers and I really have to say
that the computer part of it appealed to
be more than any of the other parts
although I like celestial mechanics but
when I finished my work doc Draper had
through his incredible influence landed
sole-source contract at the laboratory
it's an expectation where I was based to
do the Apollo guidance system in late 61
and with Bob Stern dick batten and hot
landing we were a group of what I think
was called advanced guidance or
something to the Apollo problem they
were other people in the Polaris side
that we're busy as well but we started
without by not really having any contact
with those folks I worked on connect
trajectories and trying to figure out
abort trajectories and so forth but
pretty soon maybe that was later but Hal
Anning had written an executive and an
interpreter for a computer which was
being proposed to be the on-board
computer for Apollo which was computer
that had originally been intended to fly
to Mars and take one photograph and come
back and drop it somewhere where it
could be retrieved it never happened but
that computer which was a 15 bit
computer of all things with three bits
for opcode and twelve bits for address
was very nicely designed it had a top
codes in 4k of memory of which I think
500 words were erasable in the restrooms
fixed memory
these folks know more about that than I
do but and Hal had written this
executive that dispatched tasks on a
priority basis and an interpreter which
was something I had never even thought
or heard of panel was probably not the
first to do that but a real pioneer in a
lot of ways but he had written his code
and I started reading it and trying to
make it better which was difficult but
it occurred to me that one of the things
that we were going to need is something
that simulated that computer because we
hadn't had a computer to to run and if
we had we wouldn't wouldn't have been
designed for debugging and so forth so
so I got eventually into the game of
writing a computer simulator for the
Apollo for that but we called them the
Mars computer and that developed over
time and I sort of skip around a lot but
who ever time into a full simulation of
the spacecraft the guidance computer all
of the hardware that interacted directly
with the computer or the control the
spacecraft and even with the crew and
including where the fixed stars were and
all the sextant operations and so forth
and ended up in the library developing
the star catalog which as far as I know
was the one that went to the moon I
don't really know I lost track of it but
they don't change very fast
so what's probably stay
and the group developed into you know
half a dozen people or so on different
aspects of writing the simulation and we
were racing to get it ready in time for
Alex's 2:02 software and I say Alex is
because he was in charge of it and bore
the brunt of all the stress other folks
just took life easy analyst but trying
to keep up with their needs to do the
simulation we had at that time I moved
from 650 powerhouse of an
instrumentation lab up to a Honeywell
machine which was designed to to do
Insurance programming I think had lots
of tape drives fun machine wasn't quite
fast enough so we eventually got a
faster one and then moved on to a
machine is that the one with queasy Oh
toilet and I remember one day we had two
360 75s that just about the world's
fastest commercially available machine's
other than maybe some of that crazy more
crazy machines and we had fixed it up so
each one had two big 2314 arrays
23:14 was a big disk drive which about
footprint of this table it had eight
multi platter discs and of nine actually
because one would fail or something I
guess it was for loading up another one
well the other ones were gonna use and
as I recall we had we had two of those
that connected to each machine and
because of cable restrictions and
distance of the machines we had a fifth
one that was sort of halfway between the
two machines with a cable running from
each so we had a shared disk and I
remember standing there thinking we have
a gigabyte of storage on us
between these machines and I thought
that was I mean it was at the time
absolutely mind-boggling
not nearly as mind-boggling as what's
happened since then you should point out
megabyte on the 75 cost about a million
dollars really either starts the machine
that I ordered the 75 that I initially
ordered had a half a megabyte of memory
and little bit I know and had fed took
423 11s because of 2314 available I
forgotten how small at 2311 at 28
megabytes
they were small and the operating system
used up I think all over this space and
all of the memory leaving no space for
anything else but memory was so
expensive we just well we had to buy it
we went up to a whole egg abite I
remember I was living in Netherlands
bought a megabyte of memory for my 80
that I had bought and rode home from the
electronics store with a megabyte of
memory in my pocket on my bicycle I
thought gee things have really
progressed my 60 gigabyte disk that I
had loved my machine and don't fits on
my shirt pocket oh just can't believe
what's happened and it is very difficult
for me having even been there and I
think for people who weren't there
almost impossible to imagine the
difficulties that people dealing with
the machine with a 15 bit word and and
lots of restrictions upon expanding it
even though the technology was available
the reliability requirements prevented
much happening that would take advantage
of what could have been done trying to
squeeze enough software in there to fly
to the moon and back into what became I
think 36k words of fixed memory in a 1k
of erasable memory
2 K and 1 K accessible and right and
squeezing that out of three bit opcode
and 12 bit address took some funny
shenanigans which caused a lot of
debugging activity but I don't think
anybody can imagine that the kinds of
problems that were faced trying to
squeeze a huge amount of software into
that tiny tiny machine which really was
well after getting the simulation group
going and there are lots of war stories
about that probably a little interest to
most and known by the folks here I
foolishly accepted the responsibility of
becoming the leader of the mission
program for the first lunar module this
was after thee all fire long hiatus of
flights during which time everybody
moved to the block to stuff and I
remember a long long time it seemed that
Alex was sweating and working on the 202
software to a4 software it never flew it
was going to fly that day which the
three astronauts died on but I went to
Alex and I don't know if alex remembers
us but I remember told a lot of people I
said Alex I didn't know anything about
the mission software I've been doing the
simulation and trajectories I know all
that stuff
Cole but I don't know anything about the
mission program what do I do
what did you do he says well any time
somebody comes to you and
what they should do make something up
and I said you're kidding
so absolutely not you said if they come
to ask you they don't know and they know
better than anybody else
so if they don't know and you don't know
you gotta make something up well he was
exactly right
could it worked you just had to not get
stuck on something you just had to take
a path and not all of the things that
either was made up probably but
certainly in my case worth but if they
didn't work you found out about it and
then somebody would come back and say
this didn't work what should I do
make up something else different and
that usually work because and you knew
it was a seat-of-the-pants a lot of the
way that's a probably a good place for
me to shut up
well I got involving the sort of a back
door he was working for Raytheon and
attached to the instrumentation lab on
the Polaris Project since the resident
and shortly after that petered out a
little bit he became reattached as a
resident on the Apollo program in the
computer group and when I just putting
things in context I was all of three
years out of school so not not what
you'd call really tremendously
experienced in computer design but got
into the computer group and was doing
work with Ramon and dr. Hopkins Dave
chance key to go ahead with the Mars
computer and then shortly after arriving
the concept of the integrated circuit
arose and I remember a meeting in Eldon
halls office where we all gathered
around and tried to determine which
direction the group ought to go as far
as implementing either with the Mars
circuit technology of the core
transistor logic or the integrated
circuit approach and all of the issues
that that was going to raise and the
decision was made to go ahead with the
integrated circuit approach of course
none of us knew what an integrated
circuit was at that time but I ended up
with the responsibility
we implementing the Mars design in the
integrated circuit world and carried
that through the very interesting
computer design many levels of
interrupts
I remember detect words like pink mink
shake and shank for essentially
instantaneous reaction to requests from
resolvers and synchros and communication
links and incorrect that and a multi
structured level of interrupts and
software levels of hierarchy I also
remember a fateful day in 1963 sitting
in the Apollo computer lab which was a
big room and then a little room behind
it I was in the little room behind it
with the first brass board Apollo
computer prototype I was debugging it
when the word came that Kennedy was shot
that was kind of a real seminal moment I
think everybody became particularly
re-energized in making this project work
and that was that was my role I did a
little bit of programming when the
design was finished to some orbital
calculations but my role was primarily
in the design of the hardware I'd like
to add something to what herb did which
was a quote which I think applies to the
business of D you could do this project
today at the time we the follow computer
first became kind of available there was
an internal need to have something that
could show that it worked not that it
did the job that this computer was alive
in her program the little game which
would be no completely primitive by
today's standards but was a little
version of pong in which the ball
bounced all over the place and it was
after doing that and then all the work
that came after that the herb I heard
her when they say you can do so much
with 4k and so little with 40 you know
you can do so much with five people and
so little 400 people all trying to do
the same job
which i think is part of it I think and
what I think the in terms of wild
project can be done
I think the genius wasn't a partitioning
of the project that you know dissipates
out several degrees as one is that we
get clear to go all the other having an
institution that was already he was
talented okay we can't do that you're
not gonna go anywhere but then the fact
that the job was broken up so that the
people go go work and as to what they
did and you know didn't have to
constantly cross-check everything at
every second that was plenty of that to
be done but I think that that's probably
one of the signal characteristics of
that project I've been in many projects
since then
everybody here has to and I think those
projects that fail almost always had the
enormous bureaucracies of cross jacking
that just didn't see where's the
partitioning was wrong the thing that's
right partitioning was attitude by
intuition or did that idea come from
somewhere well generally there's there's
somebody's there's gotta be a
combination of political and technical
architecting done I don't know this any
one person but I think the lab had first
of all their lab was divided by
stovepipes of the worst of those the
desirable there's a platform group then
there were the single conditionings and
there then the optic scope and then they
the computer group which was kind of a
foreign object in the lab as I recall
for many years the but that so that that
partitioning by discipline already
existed but even within that well I
think once the job was done that there
was gonna be a midterm guidance center
and a booster guidance and every entry
and there's going to be an abort you
know all these things were partition is
probably Devi Horus was the person who
who just thought that this is the way
the life that the world should be so I
think that it requires a architecting
visionary on that so
or spaceflight it says a lot of periods
of thrust activity periods just tracking
where you are flying to and so some of
the partitioning just came from the
separation by periods of point in a
narrative flight you want us to throw
over there should we all start earnest
sure to make domicile yours why I think
two things one the overall speed I think
you got a look there was a totally
different era it sort of had followed
not that long after World War Two and it
still had the spirit of whatever you got
to do you got to do it quick and and
done because it was a per you know
pressure and the aerospace industry for
instance started with nothing when the
forty one and by forty five they had
built three hundred thousand airplanes
and bombers and transports so they had
an industry that really tool up and
moved fast and after Sputnik we were in
another mode of moving that way some of
us had worked with Davey Howe egg on the
Polaris and we worked on the guidance
and so forth but those guys want to have
no Rayburn and the special projects they
started to go in eighteen months they
had a submarine built and ready to take
a missile base shark I mean imagine
sitting downs now saying somebody go and
saying oh and have building a submarine
having it out there in eighteen months
he couldn't do the paper worked in
eighteen months but those guys really
really moved I never quite understood
well they took a submarine that existed
and split it in two and redid took all
sorts of tricks to do it but with those
of us who worked on that also saw that
whatever you did it was going to move
very very rapidly and we had Davey Howe
egg to petition to lead us who's really
a genius as far as I'm concerned a lot
of us think he's the mentor for
engineering showed us what engineering
really was then when we moved to Apollo
which Davey said last time was August 8
1961
in Washington when it when they awarded
it and some of us were there then we
were there for even the start but it
started as Jim said then they started
put together teams there's a little
before but not much and built in late 61
but you got to have two
there's really two distinct phases with
different objectives and organization
first is the engineering phase that
lasted well two to four or five years
depending on what part and that's when
you had powered flight rendezvous I was
in the re-entry something else Lam later
but I don't know that it started that
way and you guys are doing the simulator
who else there was about five or six
groups but it was definitely engineering
organized two different parts of it and
dick batten was the guy that ran all of
it but we were all involved he didn't
really run he just nod and let you do he
presided and he was a real hands-off
real hand you all right just a guru
right in his corner very smart in his
corner and smoked his pipe but not me so
he was just writing a book but by god he
knew exactly what was going on and he
didn't interfere and to me that is one
of the secrets of success again I said
as I said before it was the few nests
the people right that allowed this
massive project to be shoehorned into
this teeny box each network engineering
groups was quite small as CEO said we
had three or four near entry and each of
these others didn't have a lot and he
had a free hand NASA was very busy with
a lot of other they had a lot of other
things cooking so we had a lot of
ability we went to these panel meetings
every month or two with in my case it
was Aaron Cohen but and a lot of other
NASA the uux you inform them what you
were doing and waited for critical
comments but you weren't
ridden yeah I had a single point of
contact at NASA
Tom Gibson remember right the
cigar-chomping guy I mean he was he
oversaw our work but he'd interfere
right we told him there were not hordes
of bureaucrats who caused you to fill in
forms and make present a briefing
we didn't have that at all but you kept
Tom happy he kept them off your back and
what you went on with the engineering
then we awoke several years later
realizing we had a big programming
problem so we switched from the
engineering develop equations make
simulations study develop guidance
equations we shifted to a different mode
we had a program to say G C and now we
needed a new organization different
people leading it the organization
changed entirely and now it was more
mission oriented where you integrated
all the needs into like he started the
202 1 and different people took over
everyone's and integrated the efforts of
these different groups and really had a
program it because in most cases the
engineers did a so-so programming job
and had to be redone and put into a form
that we're all consistent for for a
particular flight and you know you found
stupid errors from engineers here and
there like somebody 4pi using 22 over 7
we kept getting errors and couldn't
figure out and then this this guy I mean
he was from the old school and there
were subtle errors that even got to the
flight you think earth rate is a
well-known constant hasn't changed very
much earth rate is earth rate but if for
us novices although we know more at the
time the earth rotates once in 24 hours
and that's what the guy used on his
calculation but that isn't right the
earth does not rotate once in 24 hours
24 hours is when it gets back to the Sun
again but if you're doing Earth's
rotation rate it actually rotates in
about 23 hours and 56 minutes as I
recall and if you use the difference
your longitudes gonna be way off which
it was and I can't remember what early
flight there was so things did get
through but the programming effort was
directed differently and organized
differently and these guys really
Margaret Alex frittata the really too
took over and
in a very good way to lead all the looks
then we had a break in dilemmas command
module Emma engineering took a lot
longer because Grumman was longer they
didn't know some of us thought we were
done and they were just almost getting
started Alan clumping and then the auto
pilots came on which required some more
engineering but anyway I've for a long
time there was a myth that was
absolutely nothing more than a myth that
each mission program was a slight
enhancement of the one that went before
so that all you had to do for the next
one was the enhancement the mythic part
was that you had to start all over again
because everything was different somehow
the hardware was different or the
mission was different or very few things
I think I mean the only one that we flew
exactly the same thing twice I don't
think there's any other maybe God did
501 and 502 were identical because they
run man there was nothing and I think it
was absolutely the same thing but I
don't think we did any others that way
but the trouble is a lot of us were
fooled into believing the myth somehow
even though after we knew it really
wasn't working that way and thought with
these small groups of people we could
handle it
yeah I remember these talks in which we
said we got to do this with either about
five people v6 or we got to do with 150
the number we've got which is about 30
or 40 is absolutely gonna kill us
keep on we have to do either one way or
the other
I think we'd happily we went to the
hundred and fifty although it wasn't fun
no it was very difficult a whole new
culture especially when you had
what's-his-name from IBM's Brooks law
that adding more people to a job that's
in trouble makes it later things like
that we couldn't figure out why anybody
else need needed to know what was in the
guidance
besides us and then what does an acid
need to know for why do we have to
publish all these documents we of course
did have to publish on one stuff
speaking of the point that the thread
apparently raised in the prior meeting
and Dan touched on I remember I
mentioned Hal Anning who had written the
executive for the Mars computer and who
stayed involved for a while but decided
even like the big money in the big
pressure one day there was a meeting
sort of late in the Apollo project in
which there was two day meeting at the
end at the laboratory about 30 people to
decide whether the executive program for
the shuttle computer should be
interrupt-driven
or scheduled driven and I'm not sure it
came to a conclusion after 60 person
days but Hal said to me these people
have just spent more time our mandates
in that meeting and it took me to
conceive of and write and debug the
executive for the Apollo computer I mean
things just had changed by orders of
magnitude and it was clear to me it
wasn't going to be fun more to work on
that sort of stuff and so I didn't
get into later and is the tail almost of
a long story of that I would I would
categorize as it almost a religious war
between the synchronous executive folks
and the intra priority driven folks and
it mushroomed in the shuttle program and
it had it route its roots you know in
Apollo and crap so I'll get into that in
a little bit later
you asked about trust in automatic
systems I remember just a short anecdote
we were visited at the laboratory one
day and I don't remember when but fairly
early on by John Glenn and Alan Shepard
and I think there was a third astronaut
I don't remember who and it was at the
time when reporters were still chasing
around after the seven astronauts and it
was a big thing the astronauts were
coming and the laboratory was sort of
showing those folks what we were doing
and one of the things that at the time
we we kind of had the arrogance to
believe we should do was to make sure
that nothing could be done by a mistake
by the crew that would endanger them so
there were a lot of tests that said if
the Delta V is in the wrong direction or
this or that I can't remember what all
the conditions were there were lots of
conditions then they couldn't execute
the proceed order to go ahead because
something was you know the software
thought something was your honor and
Shepard with his marvelous way about
words I remember two things he said
there but this one said you guys think
you know more about what is gonna face
us during flight then we will know
during the flight says you're wrong you
said take all of those inhibitions out
he said look we want to kill ourselves
less could make saving ourselves and of
course he was right and I think
everybody sort of woke up to that I made
just software a lot easier - it did let
him start the pre-launch program on the
way
really weren't capable of perfection but
Abraham they were pretty well trained
and they certainly were moved over
they're very well trained I will say
that but they also got very tired
I had the Rihanna trick which is at the
end of the five days out there and they
swore through all the early years that
they were gonna fly it manually as far
as I know none of them ever touched the
manual stick I mean they were so beat
and then all of a sudden you get seven
G's I can I'm not sure they could even
see what was going on by that because I
mean they didn't get any sleep out there
for all that time that really did they
I'm surprised they were it's doing as
well as they did after all that time
yeah I think are we had a different
opinion of this subject matter than the
instruments did are at least the
software group did that at the time this
took place that pre-launch and we talked
about that the last time
when we selected pre-launch during
flight so I think there's sort of a in
between sort of you don't want to overdo
it but you also want to make the crucial
areas where you can't have a catastrophe
Shepard in that meeting was responsible
I think for the demise of another
thought that we had had which was the
computer not being perfectly reliable it
was going to be possible to do in flight
repairs and so there are a lot of
thoughts about diagnosing what had gone
wrong and changing modules and so forth
I don't know how far along that got the
Shepards comment to that was yeah and we
should all trained to be brain surgeon
so we can operate on each other and I
think that was about the end of the
in-flight repair people are talking
about that somewhat different there was
the sort of small group
seat-of-the-pants
effort that was unfettered and
unhindered for the most part by by NASA
and d'void pretty much of real
bureaucracy and I think that as Dan
pointed out you had a lot of the
fundamental engineering work was done
during that that period and and and it
was very fortunate that we were able to
do it unfettered because I think that a
lot of the fundamental issues on how to
get to the moon let's say were solved in
this period of isolation or almost
isolation and that's small groups and
these various flights uh that that have
been talked about I think the term when
Alex was talking the term system mother
conquer came into my head and and this
was a person who
the responsibility was focused upon this
person for for a particular flight even
though it was a relatively small group
but I think this era was I would say
this is the prebuilt indle era mm-hmm
and I think that somewhere along the
line someone did some let's say back of
the envelope calculations about how many
lines of code we have to do how many
person months how many lines of code for
person month and things like that and
came up with a number of people that
were just completely different than what
the lab had in doing this work so
instead of having 30 people we needed
200 people or something like that and
not only that but we needed all this
documentation and we needed all these
review meetings that we needed all NASA
supervision and we needed a lot of stuff
and and at that at that point there was
a lemon that was being split off and we
sort of became quote-unquote
professionalized in the sense that I
remember one day and I can remember the
day very very clearly that there was an
evening meeting about 7:30 in the
evening and with Ralph Reagan running
the meeting and and the lab had been
under a lot of pressure in previous
weeks with respect to NASA coming down
and questioning their organization and
questioning their documentation and
questioning their testing and
questioning everything and I was told
that evening that we could have
different organization and we're gonna
have something called project managers
and we didn't have any project managers
we didn't have that title anyway even
though you might
think of a role other being a project
manager and that's when I was appointed
the project manager of CSM software and
another individual George cherry was
appointed the project manager of LEM
software and these groups now were
fairly large and NASA wanted to see
formal schedules and and you know time
to complete this module and time to
complete that module on reporting on a
on a monthly or so whatever can't even
remember the schedule that what it was
but things started to build up in
reviews and and paperwork and then
monitoring and and and so on and I would
say that that became a different era of
doing work at the lab and much less fun
for a for for a lot of people can you
can you put a date on that switch was
after Gemini that NASA yeah I would say
I'm guessing and I'm doing it on my own
my own time schedule I would say it it's
either in the fall of 1960 I think it's
the fall 1966 or I don't think it's in a
67 but I I 60 stop when you were I think
it was the fall of 1966 and what I think
will actually prompted the change in
their attitude was it concerns the one
particular faith well I think that's a
very good question and I have a I have
an opinion but it's just a completely
personal view the people at MIT were
very smart very talented
we certainly produced a lot but we were
also I think sort of arrogant from the
outside and I
that I think that that arrogance started
to irritate people who were tired of
hearing that
am I to knew best and knew better and
you don't even know what you want we
know what you want and so on and I think
that that was part of why there was a an
effort to Saul most sort of rein in MIT
or to get them on this program not their
own program and then that vassals of
course not not not MIT and I think there
was a little bit of that plus there may
have been some perfectly honest
professionals at NASA who had had
experience with large large programs and
just felt that this was not going to get
there in the manner in which it had been
it had it had been going so far so I
don't recall in a particular conflict
that that may have prompted well not
they those operations guys did you see
down all those rooms in Houston we're
doing first mercury and Gemini and
zillions of them are flight controllers
and all of a sudden they said now what
are we going to do for Apollo and they
had nothing in a way of documents
procedures all of it was really
scandalous I can remember this they had
a it NASA at Houston on the seventh
floor and building one I think had this
beautiful conference room really
beautiful conference
and that's what they held a lot of their
big big conferences and they built a
wall on this conference room of sliding
sort of translucent boards that were
like this blackboard like whiteboard and
they were white and they were they went
deep like six deep so that you didn't
push one and there's one behind it and
push another one and he had a big long
was about the size of this wall and you
could move things from one side to the
other its own and on this wall they
created a schedule like like a today
like we call a Gantt chart and and they
had somebody who was taking care of this
some contractor who would come up every
day with his blue tape or red tape or
yellow tape and Mark where the schedules
were all these things on what was going
on and they could roll this this board
back from that borden and and and so on
and this was being kept
eventually kept daily by this by this
contractor and it was I was magnificent
to see it that's how much they got into
the schedules and and they sort of the
project management of the program yeah
an MIT was woefully unprepared for all
was tons of stuff and support and and so
forth so they had a reorganized - all
together and it would have been I don't
know how it would have worked there were
a few people like Fred who really did
great job of dealing with him and trying
to shape the rest of us up put on some
reasonable form for it plus there was
built in dough that you have Tindall
grams that we dealt with who was up here
a lot trying to work the problems they
would have said
days and say what you may he did a great
job and trying to mash the kind of
seriously adapting these techniques in
your own group or were just kind of
shielding that group from from from that
allowing you know kind of old practices
in the groups I was there was a certain
amount of shielding but I I would have
to say personally I was trying as a
project manager to adopt project
management methods and I was trying to
keep track of schedules and I was trying
to encourage people to document things
and put documentation in listings and
and and so on and so on so in that sense
I was I was almost one of the enemy if
you want to put it that way because the
there are there there there were a lot
of people in there and I'm sure looking
back at it people would still have those
feelings that this was just this all
this nonsense was just getting in the
way of getting this job done no well
that NASA did it just didn't view it
that way I mean that's that was part of
the job you had to you had to work to
schedules you had at us who you had to
work to you had to have reasons why you
couldn't meet a schedule you couldn't
just say well you know I promised this
in two weeks and I couldn't get it you
know I was I think well one thing that
helped it was a matrix the matrix
management 7 Utley was and so Fred in
George at that time were project
managers that
there were the functional managers so
while they were worried about the
schedules of each mission and the
functional people are worried about hey
is this stuff working you know that the
stuff we're supposed to be delivering
they'd be actual maybe the man-machine
interface part I mean this was a whole
separate division so the functional
people and the project managers would I
thought they work together very well
well there was a certain there's always
tension in a matrix organization but
Fred did a great job because he came to
us and didn't wasn't as high-handed as
some people at NASA pounding on the
table give me this or else
fred was like a psychiatrist project
right Fred psychiatrist drawn from the
ranks so he understood I mean I was sort
of you friends mister powered flight
that probably was a fairly short period
in when you look well any like you were
so you were one of the guys that I
needed so that in powered flying well
Samantha I just remember Fred
actually I say that from the the
background of people it's interesting in
those days you've caused have physicists
on the job and and mathematicians and
engineering graduates and students but
we'd probably had a literature major
here and there too was who jumped in
there but there was no computer science
discipline as such there's nobody there
was a computer scientist per se and then
teach and I don't think they even taught
it
of course but I often felt that part of
our success at that time was due to the
engineering and physical science
backgrounds of a lot of those people
because they they maybe they they
weren't the most elegant programmers
okay but they understood what a specific
impulse of an engine was or what what
what the physics of the what you were
trying to do and you weren't taking
somebody who was a sort of from the
inside of a computer and then trying to
who knew that and then trying to get
them to understand the problem that you
were trying to solve and I'm not saying
they couldn't do that but I'm just
saying that at that time I thought that
one of the one of the reasons that we so
rapidly was able to do this I think
there was a great understanding of what
the problem was and even if we had to do
some fast learning but people had the
basic tools I think that was important
yeah I remember
I lost rated before I remember when you
joined Margaret and I didn't want to
tell us against you but one of the first
things I did in interfacing with you was
explained in the inertial navigation
system to you and you were a math major
if I remember rightly and you hadn't
worked you understood but you hadn't
work with coordinate systems and I spent
you know a couple of hours a couple of
days teah going through what the basis
of the guidance system was and how it
working low I never talked to her again
because you understood and you became an
inertial at least somebody who's who
knew what inertial navigation system how
you describe them at how you can throw
why about something that Jim didn't said
and what it what he did in that group
there was another fellow who I
perhaps should be here as well also
contribute exactly this bill would know
you know we we needed those simulations
so much because it was the only thing
that grounded us to the to what the
truth was I mean you could never tell
with what you were doing was gonna work
until you banged it against a simulator
unless the simulation was wrong unless
the simulation was wrong and I didn't I
suppose that happen I don't know that's
why I'm so important
I don't remember times and I was really
impressed when you know somebody had
five five degrees of freedom in the in
in the fuel sloshing module of her of
the of the vehicle and they had you know
all the stars in the right places and
all uh everything else that would that
would happen and it was really it became
our sort of truth and I was thinking
about this year last night before I came
here also that you know this was a
father a basically a fun project
although there were plenty of difficult
times in the project when you're in the
middle of it but I was we did a lot of
testing in this project a lot of testing
with these simulators and I think that
if all we ever did was fly the nominal
mission so that with nothing wrong
living pretty boring infrared for a
while you had this just one set of
parameters and you always fly one set of
parameters and I think that part of the
fun that we had was thinking up and
creating these crazy off-nominal cases
that probably could never never happen
but and then see and then bang
against the software that we designed
and design certain margins into the
software that would all that would make
sure that you know that that if you
which way or what way the gimbal would
go that you know you'd be able to get
get out of it and and other things that
made that made such variety in the I
forgot in the testing that for the for
one nominal case you know we ran a
hundred dollar all cases no it's also an
advantage from a software of computer
science or software engine engineering
point of view of having different
missions is that we learned all about
the advantages of things that people
don't think too much about today like
reuse and how that would could cut down
on testing or you know we learned all
the things about what it means to manage
these different missions what's reused
between the lemon the command module
between this mission and the one that's
going next how do you evolve how do you
do it in a reliable way
in other words it it was a great place
to learn about how to do things the
right way so that was the whole thing
had to be structured to I mean that's
all that software had to be really we
structured it into programs with me with
numbers we call them things we had names
for them the astronauts eventually
picked up some of those same names they
would get into p40 I mean they they
didn't know what p4 it was these these
things were not not that that not that
those names were so great but the fact
of the matter is that that software all
had to be structured and organized and
and there had to be a nomenclature on it
had to be interfaces but build they took
on a life of their own took our like
banks manually here there
and it had to be ready about what was it
810 weeks before flight time you
couldn't change it after that and also
we learned about how important it was to
prioritize as to what was most important
because there was so little room to put
programs into that you would learn to
delete what was less important but
prioritizing became something and backup
systems also became something that
becomes it you you lived your life later
by doing things like prioritizing and
doing things like having backup systems
in your daily life going to the grocery
store later on it was such an influence
but we had a black friday and i can't
remember what black friday was i just
remember we were deleting all kinds of
things because something more important
was coming in what's called assignments
were they cut cut I think they called a
like Black Friday you know but we
deleted an awful like is something
really important had to be done maybe it
was backup sir or I don't never know I
wrote about it but I can't remember
whatever go back and I'm sorry you'll
have to leave thank you very much come
on tell you very either the person who
inflicted banks on us ever worry about
it that was a solution to make that
problem
very bad problem
I think solution exists today in Windows
right there are the six architecture
because you still have to do banking in
order to get the extended address fields
it was almost like area codes I would
say that in a in the telephone system I
mean you had to you had to be able to
address this with the with the
addressing how many bits you had for
addressing and in order to get unique
addressing it had to have you had to
mark it with another set of fee another
field that would let you address
uniquely and and so you had to manage
that other field and I got very
confusing than the software was a
difficult issue and the erasable memory
was so small as it to capture the
certain of it was permanent but a lot of
it like used during burn and when you
were done burns that same area was used
for something in a later phase and so
these phases were sequential and all the
previous information was gone and not
used anymore so you didn't have unique
see there are a lot of things to do with
interfacing correctly and therefore we
had the opportunity to make a lot of
interface errors because we had to
squeeze everything into such a small
space but also it's amazing what
one could do so little space and how
much how little one can do with so much
space today okay one of the things that
this remark I have marked on the lace to
myself over 30 years since then is at
the time we brought software into a
machine that by today's standards would
be a very advanced architecture I mean
we had you heard it all the time
pre-emptive event-driven executives I
mean I've worked with people who said
what you programmed into one of those a
real-time control computer with
event-driven asynchronous we don't have
that today with yeah with auto pilots
and jet sending signal across multiple
levels of interrupts and control we
invented it for this job and it it
hasn't reached as a standard of computer
design today there are surely there are
interrupts of stuff like but not they
were not used in this coordinated
fashion that we had them something else
that we invented and it's saving those
guys funds on the moon was the software
restart which allowed in reaction to a
any kind of failure for the computer to
re-track back to its last known properly
coordinated state and to read move
forward you don't have to do
control-alt-delete know this thing sense
what do we call those things restart
restart points as we went along and Dan
was the father of that I was gonna say
this guy and woody Vandiver I was dance
the father woody was the guy who put
together and that they advised that
woody should be hazed either but not
only did they the software reach that
concept I think rescued that the limb
from failure just had the touchdown um
they were also a terrific help and
debugging this complex piece of software
who we used them I remember that we
triggered restarts because if this thing
was able to
to to go over the same piece we could
change things and rerun chunks using the
characteristics of the software itself
and I think Margaret was probably
remembers more of that the night around
if we did not have that testing this
real-time software to be nicer you
brought up something that was really
interesting because people today when
they use computers they try something
doesn't work they try something else but
again doesn't work and they just had the
computer at their disposal we could only
put in runs overnight so you'd have to
think very carefully because if it
didn't work then you'd have to wait till
the next day he wasted a day a whole day
so then what we learned to do was to
find a way to run like a hundred runs at
once thinking about it before the fact
and the restarts remind me of that so
you try all these different things all
at once and in a way you got more done
because you had to think it out so
carefully you got done maybe more in
that 24-hour period than if you were
sitting here ad hoc lis just trying
something and so you're basically doing
things more in parallel I think in your
thinking process in your design
the test so that was totally I don't
know what lessons can be learned from
that but yeah we did this with cars
offline
yeah cars thank you there were no such
things as terminals interaction that's
Margaret said you you gotta get back a
stack of 2000 cards you gave it to the
guys in the computer but by then it'll
cordon themselves off me you couldn't we
used to go in there and run the runs
ourselves but that in some states when
Jim's double Honeywell came in that was
the end of that and the thing is if you
drop the cards you had a real problem
but it made you realize I mean that was
part of the reason we worked on doing
something where if you drop the
instruction sets it wouldn't matter
because it was smart enough to get it
back together again
that was later but we used to take
pieces of cards and say here put this in
your deck and that would be the reusable
the other 19 these are like horror
stories of war stories there's probably
something to be learned from this
experience that the few under arduous
circumstances were able to turn out
something as complex as this piece of
software was and have it work and prove
that it worked that seems to be missing
today I don't know how to put that
together but the few people and the more
crude the development environment was
that better seemed to have been the
progress in the end product this is a
conundrum sure we did something that I
know Margaret was intimately involved
with and that is it I think it's it's
written up in in Microsoft's method of
doing their software today we had a
daily nightly configuration control
group that that looked at all changes
that were created by anybody during the
day and had it had to pass this little
group of people which might have been
four people and and we had the mothers
but we had this quote advantage of doing
an A in assembly every night so that so
that these changes were brought in to
one with one listing you might say and
and then by the next day you'd have the
update of that program and so you had a
very extremely tight configuration
control system now today if everybody's
programming on on monitors and they're
all distributed and so on this is a much
more difficult environment than we were
in this one building everybody producing
changes and cards and and and and and
write-ups of what their changes were all
being funneled to one small
configuration control group who would
then pass on everything that went into
that system and and that was done
continuously I don't know if started
right at day one but it was done on the
flights that I remember and it was a
very effective way of keeping errors out
of the out of the program but there was
more to add to that and then
every single day the person who reviewed
the changes would put out a memo that
would go to everyone that was involved
in that mission so that they were aware
of what the changes were so that then if
they had problems they know that a
change had been made in that area so it
was that communication just you know
hardcopy memos that went out alongside
each daily revision could be forgotten
that this was an assembly language
program if somebody had set up a
simulation with what we call special
requests addressed to certain locations
and somebody changed the underlying
stuff the locations could move in that
simulation run would just be incorrectly
formulated as it would turn out but that
would take a day and so you had to be
careful not to kill somebody by taking
shooting down something somebody else
was planning to do with a fixed
configuration when she wasn't ever fixed
because somebody had to change something
every day towards the end of the
development of a single mission program
this is a fascinating thing it's been
mentioned that NASA let us do just about
anything we wanted to in the code we did
have some help from a famous guy at TRW
but they say basically we were
completely given free reign until we
delivered the software to Raytheon to
build the coral and then we would go
into a series of tests with absolutely
fixed configuration the purpose being to
find anymore bugs that hadn't been found
and sometimes when you found sometimes
you would find bugs that just you felt
had to be fixed and usually they it
could be but once the program was
delivered this group of people who were
the only people in the world who NASA
thought could write the software
suddenly were so stupid that no change
that he proposed could be plausible at
all and so anything you suggested the
answer
No you know you had their bag and so
forth for the interest of the project to
be allowed to remove this desperately
bad thing and I remember one night in
the lemon software game when one of
these showed up probably with a digital
autopilot which was new and it was late
at night it must have been dining or
10:00 at night and I called the guy and
I'm not gonna mention any names for
reasons that you'll see I called the guy
who was monitoring us at NASA at home I
had to get his permission to put this
change in and to let him know it was
coming and his wife answered the phone
and said he was at work so I called him
at his office nobody there
well I knew that this guy wasn't always
telling his wife what he was up to
they say that news day and here I was
with this problem it was 10 o'clock at
night we wanted to put this change in it
was in my mind whatever it was really
important to put this change in I knew
the guy wasn't where his wife thought he
was and I didn't know what to do I
couldn't leave him a message at work
because they didn't have voicemail and I
didn't want to call his wife back and
say he wasn't at work for fear of what
would happen to him when he got home and
what do you do in a case like this we
were absolutely at the mercy of getting
approval of those things I don't
remember what what happened what
but there were some funny situations
like that there were many times the the
software was changed after the Rope had
actually been built sometimes have
already potted it and have to be part of
them changed the wires and so forth
it was incredibly small and arduous
process one of the things that I think
deserves mentioned illustrated them the
frugality that went into the design and
the software was that the the guys that
invented these interpreters and we had a
second generation of them later than the
one developed realized that
single-precision was too small to do
earth to moon navigation but double
precision was adequate and so the
interpreter would do everything and
double precision or lots of things in
double precision it was a ones
compliment machine which was funny
enough by itself so that there were
three thousand 32767 States not 32,768
states and unfortunately there were some
optical encoders on rotating gadgets
that needed to the fifteen exactly and
not to the fifteenth minus one and so it
also was capable of doing two's
complement arithmetic which caused some
other problems but here we had a ones
compliment machine with two forms of
zero and double precision in which the
interpreter was perfectly happy to let
the two parts of the world have
different signs so you could have a plus
one over here and a minus half over here
and the result would be whatever it is
plus a half and that was clever because
the software to do sign correction all
the time took time took space and was
eliminated
unfortunately however there were a lot
of cases where that just turned out to
be
real pain in the backside and there were
lots of little bugs that showed up when
there was sign disagreement in the in a
way that somehow got through all the
checks there and so there were things
that we did to ourselves sometimes in
the interest of frugality it was it was
a different day it was a different day
danik or saw the assembly language
problem he solved lots of problems wrote
an assembler we had an assembler on the
Honeywell machine which was a batch
assembly you would take all of the
assembly programs that you were going to
update and you'd assemble this huge deck
of cards it would affect all of them one
of the characteristics of this assembler
was it was designed for a tape machine
so tapes and receive something down and
so forth was if your cards were in the
wrong place or had the wrong number on
they wouldn't go where you put them in
and they wouldn't necessarily even go
into the program that you had a main
down and so you had to meticulously
check your summary listing in the
morning when you got it to see if all
your changes went in there and if they
weren't were you expected them you had
to go try to figure out where did they
go and it was a it was an arduous
process and a careless person could
rehab on the world in that opposite
assembly and they would run for a long
time a saving grace of the Apollo
computer was that it was slow and why I
say that was that the simulations that
we did in assembly to be ended were very
long and if the machine had been ten
times as fast it would have taken ten
times longer on the best hardware that
we could buy to simulate this time and
we would never have been able to run
these simulations they would have just
taken more time than we hit then we
could
possibly have so sometimes the limited
resources are blessing in disguise
otherwise those emulators people have
today's computers have so much trouble
they're trying to emulate something
that's so fast we had things in the
simulation called clock advanced which
you tell a simulator you were willing
when nothing was happening to just jump
the clock up to the point where
something happened and the simulator
would figure out when that was and just
they have leap up there and it really
advanced the speed of the simulation to
the point where it was nearly real-time
in a lot of cases depending on how busy
the computer was but there are lots of
periods where it was just idling and
maybe a few instructions or maybe a few
seconds but you would just leave the
clock forward and that far as I know it
never caused any any difficulties
because we didn't pass anything where if
an interrupt happened we that's where we
go or so have something else there are a
lot of tricky stuff in there I keep
telling people what that simulator used
to do and they can't believe it there's
many things that did that people don't
do today that they should do one of the
fascinating problems was the reuse of
erasable memory and like every memory
problem a piece of software that would
use somebody else's memory would likely
get away with it because if it started
writing into that area and then
completed what it would do it would go
away and then the person who had left
something in there for its use when it
came back would hit something that
somebody else had written in there and
go completely wrong and then by then the
real violator was long gone and you
hadn't forgot who did it and there were
also problems of using erasable that
hadn't been initialized the way you
thought of had and we came up with a
technique to put kind of a random number
into all of erasable when we started
if that was ever hit you could see it
and and we had a way to put that same
random number back in so you could do
kind of diagnosis to find it there were
just things that let me know what it
doesn't you know they still didn't solve
that you don't know how many students of
my night now their programs only work
when there's zero and you know location
when they start that's the worst thing
I've decided that you could put in an
unused that's why are people doing these
things there are so many things that
would really help debug systems today
that that never were brought forward
many things are but that was one that
was I think more advanced than most
debugging tools we have why do you think
that is what was any effort to
disseminate in a systematic way the kind
of knowledge and programming that we get
you gain within that project to you know
in a flesh how the most important
principle that that'll worked out on the
work with this project and publish them
there have been a few summaries of the
probe the the program that people have
written volumes I think that you
probably have gotten your hands
I know there was a late volume written
by that woman Madeline sold solo
Sullivan and some time she wrote a
multi-volume history of Apollo I think
it was one of the lab documents but I
don't know that anybody has tried to
record the essence of let's say
programming breakthroughs or programming
inventions or something of that nature
or or the salient discoveries if you
will in there in the Apollo I haven't
seen anything now that I don't think so
some parts of the engineering have been
covered with some good paper
well battens got a book but that's more
theoretical but I haven't there been
some papers on lemon water pilot lunar
land perhaps i bill wrote oh so we wrote
a book on autopilot right I think it was
to see a semi auto pilot but right
published by MIT press that's vaguely
coming back maybe that's what enough to
many people were thinking of publishing
they were trying to just get them get
home I mean I don't know how many people
were working six or seven day week Sadie
yahooeys and doing everything they
possibly could in their power to get
this yet guys to the moon a number of
marriages yeah sank I didn't have period
including mine I think there was an
element in this program that is missing
in a lot of current programs and
the 6070 our week that we just taught
spoke about I'm sure that people do that
today too but there wasn't I don't know
how to say this a an immediacy or a
familiarity with the astronauts I was
talking about people at MIT but it's
probably true in other parts of the
Apollo program that you felt a certain
personal responsibility to either you
made promises or you had conversations
with these people or you were doing it
because you because you wanted to make
sure that there was absolutely zero
errors in this program because the you
know their lives were at stake there was
some sort of connection to the
astronauts that that we had I felt that
I think other people at MIT felt perhaps
because they came in for training or or
I know there were occasions we went to
dinner with dr. Everett Lock overs with
some some of the astronauts after after
a flight and I think that affected some
the or in kept morale up and kept
people's attention and feeling of
dedication to the job because of that
sort of connection you got you aren't
working for something big necessary is a
big bureaucracy it was this in my case
it was sort of a feeling that sort of
some sort of connection with Chris Kraft
that that you were satisfying his his
leadership you might say Plus this
feeling this this sort of feeling of the
astronauts I
I would say that certainly affected me
in the job absolutely they were here I
mean what which Apollo flight had Jim
McDivitt Dave Scott and rusty
Schweickart that was Apollo 7 whatever
but they seem to be around frequently
before that and you just seemed to see
them doing this stuff and get to know
what they were doing all the time they
felt very close in fact we used to laugh
at them picking on their Scotford he
wasn't quite as fast as picking up the
stuff when you showed show them that but
they were they were there frequently but
even before that I remember the first
time we went to Houston and gave a
presentation to a lot of them that was
earlier in them still in the engineering
mode I mean these guys came out they
didn't just sit there nod off they were
excited and asked I remember Neil
Armstrong overwhelming without the
questions he asked and how well-prepared
not thoughtful and I said geez these
guys they there's no foolin them they
know they know what they're looking for
and we better be really careful at
what's going on here and make sure we're
prepared when they ask questions like
that you can't wing it well they
actually interested in software as such
not some word doctors say but they want
to know how this worked and what was
going to happen see what I'm saying to
them and how it they work through the
controls but a lot of controls are
driven by the software so what they said
or didn't say it had a immediate impact
on that of us who making those things
work in the front through the software
itself remember Steve cops there was the
man I forgot what the hell that thing
was oh you should make a note document
that gave the whole sequence is right
there weren't for John G sub G system
operations plan Steve and Malcolm and
Jack Schiller cleared all cranked out
all that stuff that was went on and on
and on the first time I'd ever seen a
specification for anything and that's
right today it is
inspect first and the software falls at
the bottom those G stops remembered John
Dolan was the guy remember him yeah the
man with the nine eight kids I think it
who lived in the South Shore somebody
came into work every day um that was a
thankless task oh yes all that stuff
yeah and you had to get it all because
he was in the other child yeah yeah
every time they had a question are they
sir can I talk to you a minute
ah yeah I still have something like
280,000 Eastern Airlines miles that are
now part of the Continental System that
never expire Wow
these were on these multiple tradition
waves already thrown in at all who's
next House of multiple trips to Houston
but one of them I want to just bring
they bring up in the conversation here I
don't know how many trips we all made to
Houston I mean and I can remember
everything I could just see myself
having this heated discussion for an
hour and a half between Boston and
Atlanta with Margaret on some
programming issue or some something that
we would do it but we attended
innumerable meetings at down at NASA and
we had a very live wire at NASA who we
went to see all the time and that was
this guy Jack Garmin who really was
he really if there was anybody at NASA
who sort of understood what we were
trying to do it was this guy Jack Garmin
and I think I always felt like hurt him
dr. Frankenstein that I created a
monster
we got assigned to me and for six months
an hour a day IKEA he was selling him
the stuff and he was persistent phone
calls phone calls home but I remember
this day this particular day that he
finished a meeting NASA and I was coming
home and we were standing
I guess walking between the parking lot
and the terminal I it was sort of like a
driveway that headed up toward the
terminal in Houston and on camera I
can't remember whether this was hobby or
the International I can't really
remember but anyway everybody said wait
a minute there's the president and so we
watched and this open car came from the
terminal past us and they were very very
many people standing around maybe two
one deep a long road that might then a
half a mile long and he drove rode by in
an open car with his wife that maybe I
thought was around 15 miles an hour but
nothing faster than maybe maybe 20 and I
remember standing there I don't know who
was with me and I said something that
you know if anybody wanted to kill this
guy this would be pretty easy because
he's just rolling by an open car as long
well that was November 21st 1963 and I
think it was a Thursday I think and I
was coming home and I was in my office
the next day no longer he said he had
gone that night and then he went to
Dallas to make the next day yeah he I
was there that same Thursday I think it
was a different meeting and he went
right down we were they did they hadn't
build the MS see yeah we were in Houston
office park whatever it was called and
he went right down the main highway
there although we didn't go out and see
him but I stayed over it all Friday and
then Friday I was heading to go home and
at the airport we got all the news and
what do you think it was a crime yeah
yeah that's what my yeah but Thursday he
was in Houston and went up and down
whatever the name of that Gulf Freeway
or whatever it is there was a parade or
something and then Friday I stayed over
Thursday night some more meetings
Thursday Friday morning was heading home
Friday afternoon and then the Hobby
Airport we heard the first news that all
of this has happened I wanted to touch
upon this religious war I mentioned
before and get into it just for a moment
the issue really came to a head in that
in the shuttle program where there were
forces that believed in a synchronous
priority driven interrupt driven
executives and other forces that
believed in absolutely synchronous
executives where you planned out all the
software and you executed the software
by tables and and you could tell what
part of the software was operating at
every instant of time because you had
planned it out so that it all operated
very rigidly and the people who really
use those kinds of executives were
mostly people in the aircraft industry
and they had come from various airplanes
where they had these computers and they
had these synchronous executives and it
was very important for them to know
exactly what was happening at every
instant of time either either from a
testing standpoint or whatever that's
that was there
mindset and the people that had worked
on Apollo for the most part
believed in this asynchronous executive
where you had priorities and you didn't
have everything structured completely
but you allowed higher priority jobs to
interrupt lower priority jobs and so on
and there was these incredible
discussions in the shuttle in the early
shuttle time in deciding what kind of a
an executive should be used and they you
operating systems should be used in the
in the shuttle and the shuttle had its
own Hardware issues with with multi
reliability strings and and an ion i/o
processor and other things that had to
be synced and so it had a lot of reasons
why this was a big issue but the roots
of the Apollo viewpoint really stemmed
back to the alarms that occurred on the
lunar landing and as you recall in that
flight when the
that delenn was coming down and all of a
sudden he had these alarms and the
astronaut kept getting these alarms he
said that he had alarms and finally
there was a decision in Houston to just
push on and he should land and whoever
made that decision Steve bales of
whoever it was either he understood what
the problem was or he felt that he well
Jack Garmin was screaming I heard it go
go go go and I don't think he had any
evidence other than they thought we had
restarted it perfectly he landed safely
and following that landing it was a just
a frantic session that yeah the at the
MIT lab to find out what in the world
was causing these alarms and it took us
the better part of 24 hours I think if I
recall and we simian going back to the
simulators we simulated this we tried
everything to make this happen and and
we could not make this happen and and it
was as if the it was as if the Machine
AGC was operating at about 25 percent
slower than it usually operates and so
we we tried a lot of things and we
couldn't make it happen eventually to
over the the suggestion of somebody who
was who worked at the Cape a lot we
tracked down the fact that they had a
switch in the wrong position and and and
it was stealing cycles and was a radar
in rendezvous switch and that made them
via that made the AGC run slower and and
because it was running slower it was
dropping low priority jobs and not
getting to these low priority jobs and
only doing the highest priority jobs and
so the the job queue filled up and been
the job queue filled up that caused this
along to go
and so on and and at any rate MIT got a
lot of criticism for software error
causing this to happen and so now you
had a sort of a dichotomy where people
believe that what had happened was
actually an error and other people
believe no the software actually saved
the program because it in the face of
this mistake in the switch the the the
software which was written as a priority
interest priority executive was able to
go on with the highest priority jobs and
not tank the mission because it didn't
have to do this boxcars structured a a
synchronous system where it would give
time to everything whether it was
important or not well you know it was
even more complicated than that because
the error was in the actual
documentation yes I was gonna mentioned
they had a moment but so this this this
feeling went forward including the NASA
folks
people like Jack took Jack Garmin who
absolutely felt that it was important to
have such a system in shuttle at versus
the air and airline air airplane folks
who felt that that that they could never
be able to test the software afterward
if they couldn't have an exact match and
knowing exactly what happened at any
time and and the synchronous exactly
asynchronous executive was almost not
repeatable you might you might say so
that that that caused a great deal of
difficulty what Margaret is pointing out
is that when we finally got and found I
remember
I remember the incident that we ran
upstairs Mars to look at the telemetry
to see where the bits was said and sure
enough the radars bit the switch the bit
which was picked up by telemetry and
downloaded that was in let's say 15 bit
or how many bits words they were the
telemetry and bit 9 or whatever it was
showed that the switch was on right
which meant that that's what it was and
eventually they they told the the ground
told the astronaut when he was about to
take off from the moon you know to put
the switch in the right position he said
in a very low key fashion but when that
was run down to the end it was found in
the crew procedures to put the switch in
this position so the next question was
well how come if you put the switch in
this position wasn't this picked up in
the in the simulators at Grumman which
these guys had been training on for I
don't know a couple of years and and in
doubt that proof crew simulator they had
always done exactly what was in the
document put the switch in that position
however that switch wasn't connected to
anything so in other words that switch
was not connected in the simulator to
the AGC which would slow them down in
that stimuli mean a crime at Grumman so
they they did they trained exactly to
what that those crew procedures said
each time and they did it on on the
landing too
well it kind of gives you an
understanding more of how important
everything is with respect to the entire
system
right I've software people where then I
can put in the other way why didn't our
simulations follow the crew procedure I
don't know that the crew did that in our
simulations I don't know I
it probably didn't I don't think it was
in our digital simulator for the C I
turn on the rendezvous rate I don't know
but when you're testing back the system
thing what would make the software do
something like that in other words you
begin to think in terms of modeling and
designing a problem from and where do
you stop you know where's the outside of
the outside but it's modeling all these
things as one system of which part is
realized as software part is people
where artists hardware but then you
begin to model it as an entire
enterprise and then simulate it as an
enterprise but it makes you realize that
when people blame something as being a
software error or hardware error you're
not necessarily sure what is it and what
does it mean to be a software error or a
hardware error and this brings up all
these questions when you have events
like this take place and we still not
solved it today I mean in the industry
so do they stick to that asynchronous
design in you know travel program this
is assuming a synchronous exact I think
that they had a mixed system the hybrid
some sort of a mixed system they had
some hardware constraints on their i/o
processors and the synchronization of
i/o with the computer that made it
impossible to have I think a purely
asynchronous
thank you so they had some real hardware
issues involved in it and and we in a
company that we reformed after the we
created a programming system for shuttle
in which we built into the programming
language the concept of a sinker a
synchronicity that is that you could
have multiple jobs and pride and
priorities and interrupts and things
like that and the shuttle people for the
most part didn't want to use that those
features that we had put in the language
we were very influenced in the language
by the experience that Apollo and so we
and and very influenced by the executive
that how Lanning had designed and the
and the manner in which he had designed
that whole thing we were very influenced
in there the language designed to take
advantage of those things of which they
were I would say used to a minor extent
in in the manner in which the shuttle
was put together um he would make him a
little break five minutes or the chain
of the tape now and then and then will
continue for about one hour
because we've started at ten fine and
it's fine okay all the time on our
Apollo we had just about no contacts of
the military the military has its own
we're worrying about military satellites
and so on but our paths just didn't
cross I don't know if shuttle is where
they finally came together but not on
Apollo there were a big difference
between the people we dealt with in
Houston and most of NASA and Langley and
the old people versus Huntsville Verner
von Braun and the German gangs down
there they did things a little bit
different Lee and so there was a lot of
difference of opinion I mean they they
built things in a certain way which was
very very
although respected gyms time and the
service I think there was an actual
disdain for the military in this program
I think that they were afraid that that
military getting sort of sort of
influence on the program in southern
fashion and you were very happy that the
program was completely open and it was
only to the public and it was all and
you could talk about it and and well
there were certain aspects that still
had the stamp of the military element
some of those initial instruments and
stuff was still classified documents if
I remember right at the beginning that
right trying to get some data because
they sprang from Polaris and things were
the computer instructions classified
nothing I thought the only thing I
remember being classified about the
computer was the oscillator frequency
because I wasn't able to get a hold of
the the palak one instructions because
of some reason I thought it would had to
do with being classified but when I
first came to learn how some fathers did
I knew you have to remember that damn
you weren't able to give me a balance
you couldn't give me a document because
it was classified like don't remember I
knew it you know what sort of source
documents that were classified so you
had to write down like I can remember
you had to write down a few instructions
to say here they are but then we have
safes and then in that building I
remember that can be actually safe yeah
you know what I kept it was in there it
was not on my classified area yeah we're
having to do with the initial I thought
it was a rocket no no didn't see how
much we were influenced have to pain any
security clearance yes get all that
security
you know but I don't know whether
nothing we ever wrote was classified
though my security clearance it was
because of Polaris but that's where he
came from and I think it was kept going
from that right then I had to get one oh
you had to go yeah although actually I
had one horse age system so maybe mine
was left over I don't know and so you
didn't have any sense it's a military
war interested in Tortola kind of
innovations that went on your project no
we never thought totalitarian I can
associate where the follower was general
Philips he didn't exactly come around
looking over our shoulder no we don't
know that I think it's a little I don't
know that we knew that they weren't
interested they just were out of sight
they just they just weren't part of I
think they just thought we were gonna
totally flop so why did they want to
talk to us yeah going to the moon was a
political thing or a military thing so
yeah there were no objective of the
military involved in it well there may
have been but there it was an evil thing
yeah I mean it might have indeed you
might be from the president yeah know
that this is an open program that this
that this is a big political show for
the world right you have everything no
cuz Sputnik happened so we had contrast
it with the Russians and there in the
middle of Siberia and nobody knows
what's going on and here this is
completely old in Russia there was
always a kind of a rule that significant
invention was made that might
potentially have military significance
they would classify
even if it was done within some open
program initially but these here doesn't
seem to be that that kind of oversight
in the sense of military searching for
things that are going on that might
potentially be important was a big
danger in that because the military it
seemed to me and the people who were in
charge of security had a
ever-expanding horizon I mean you'd have
everything being classified because you
you know you couldn't tell whether this
little gizmo might have military
significance so that for a while you'd
wind up with you know almost everything
that's what the Russians oh yeah so I'm
getting a sense that there was a lot of
interaction small groups while working
on those programs or did you have mostly
in one program one programmer or several
programmers working in one program how
knowledge about what was in her prime
and each other's no area well you had
you know you had different areas I mean
if somebody was working a navigation
module they probably did not have too
much contact with some people who were
working in powered flight so they were
worried about star sightings and and
covariance matrices and things having to
do with the navigation computations but
somebody else is worried about portal
pilots and and how they were gonna fire
engines and so on and they were aware of
each other but they may not be very
strong interfaces between them and and
these two groups I would say they might
be you know you might have a powered
flight group of maybe six people and and
and you know a navigation group of some
other number like that and you had
people who were testing and you had
people who are writing and specs and so
I say you had a lot of programming group
so when you add it up you get to the
numbers we're talking about but each
group was a somewhat contained group
yeah there was a parallel group of
analysis guys that sort of her writing
testing algorithms and so forth there
weren't really writing so for
yesterday's component because then
that's right programmer was not you know
a job description
some people programmed and did analysis
and some people only did analysis
somebody did all the work in Mac this
this analytical program primarily
playing which we had I've got the brunt
of that because I remember in trying to
put this first flight program of which I
was the inaugural Rope mother together
I had the interface with these groups
and make their stuff meet the stuff of
the next group remember putting that the
launch people stuff which is just plain
analyzing dynamics and funny of where we
were to the powered flight people who
steered the thing and took over the
mission at that point then it went into
this mid-course thing with some of these
Star sighting people who were wacko
analysts I mean day one I still to this
day don't really understand some of that
that was a whole different regime
because he had ten minutes was a short
time for these guys whereas one second
was a lot to the power tonight people
and then I survived going through that
mid cool stuff got all their stuff
straight was able to then power up this
guy who was the entry he'd been working
this I remember the first day of
emulation knitted these two faces
together then we got a coordinator so
these guys program then raised program
and threatened company and something and
all my glue that I had hung this thing
together with actually worked but there
were a lot of different programming
styles and conventions that you have to
straighten out you know these guys
expected they're dealt of these and some
we were giving it in the wrong one yet
that you know this kind of thing so
putting these cells together was an
integration job we didn't integrate at
the beginning it was not a programming
exercise for the whole mission there
were these analytical
some pleaded program some who didn't
different styles there were no standards
all that received a lot more discipline
and method to remind you and let you
hang it up that you had that we didn't
have more interface type errors because
we did have no standards we had no
programming standard each group or each
little entity would would have a style I
think when I when we got this product
reading manager I mean I did try to some
extent to to get some standardization
but it was hard I think people use
different expressions for constants in
their in their programs yeah but don't
forget bowler and the stuff he did with
ICD something that we hadn't had a
function like that with all of the specs
from all of us other vendors as well as
our own we would have really been up a
creek I mean that was another guy I
remember even bigger Peter Peck yeah it
was bigger instituted control of over
revisions and stuff
I don't know that group that you said
that took over wasn't that Peters group
well he started I mean when he did it I
don't know where he thought this needed
to be done and he started doing it I
mean there was no you of the
configuration that here she you know
started that kind of stuff of me come
and argue with you couldn't put changes
in that day and stuff
and you don't want to sit on you like
this but we invented that in the course
of the work that certainly were
integration problems outside our
building and I think that our experience
within the building and we were all
within where relatively well controlled
but some of the interface problems we
had that were experienced between our
stuff and other people's stuff and
between various other people's stuff I
remember for example was at 5:01 day at
5:02 where there was an engine failure
and the software nothing to do with us
shut down another engine thinking that
they were shutting down the one that had
failed it so it was two engines out of
five right we ended up in orbit and they
were supposed to do a translunar
injection but because of the failure
they didn't have an s4 be left or
whatever it was we ended up instead of
on a trajectory headed towards a trance
lunar we ended up either in orbit or an
elliptical thing so instead of doing a
bird to knock us out of a trance lunar
trajectory we burned first to put us in
then we turned around knocked us out
that was one example of one of these
integration problems that woke up a lot
of people I think the accident on the
pad was probably the single biggest
disaster that will people up and stop
the project for about a year and a half
or something long investigations were
done and block two was invented there
hustled into place the mission that I
was involved with them which was
subsequently called Apollo 5 which we
called Apollo 2 or didn't call Apollo 2
or 6 it was 206
first flight of the land marches on
this is the flood I think I mentioned
the last time this is one that only that
it was at the Cape and the engine shut
off in two seconds of four seconds well
I'll mention a little bit about what
happened because I think it's was it was
revealing
we never flown a Grumman spacecraft
before and I've never guided one we
never flown a block to system we've
never flown a digital so there was a lot
of new stuff and the throat mother was
new and we had a lot of veterans and a
lot of other people who were new and our
relations with Grumman were different
than the relations with North America
where they always talked last time about
it was just a whole different ballgame
and I for one had never had any contact
with the Mission Control people and
didn't have much as it was but I went
down there to one flight procedures
meeting was run by the guy who was gonna
be the flight director I mean not
mention his name but it was a terrible
meeting I thought I mean the guy was so
arrogant and obnoxious that people just
stayed quiet and probably should have
asked questions are spoken up but in the
event of the flight we had the first
burn scheduled and although it simulated
lots of times when the command went to
the engine unknown to me as a program
mission program guy and as the
simulation guy there was a lot of
pressurization of tanks and stuff that
took place between the fire signal and
when the engine actually lit up and we I
had been told by the guy that wrote
descent burn software that it had to
have a very narrow window on the startup
because of something or other I don't
remember what but we had a fairly narrow
into it and it was the timing of the
interrupt and so forth it just missed
reaching the Delta V threshold by
milliseconds if I remember and so we
shut it down the software shut it down
and utter chaos took place in Mission
Control Center I mean everybody was
climbing all over everybody to find out
what happened
totally preventing anybody from finding
out what happened because managers were
insisting on knowing stuff that you
didn't know yet and it was bad procedure
and I don't know if that continued on
other flights but it certainly screwed
occasionally you Houston man all right
I'm sorry we had put in there as a part
of the mission software a very clever
and fairly extensive ability to
reprogram all of these burns and when we
through the hierarchy of Jack Garmin up
to the flight director told him that
that we could easily reprogram this
thing and try it again
the answer was it's no longer within
telemetry coverage somehow they had
designed this mission unbeknownst to us
in a way that there was no possible way
to use this reprogramming stuff if
anything went wrong the course was the
only purpose for which this
reprogramming software was in the flight
computer but there was no tulleken
coverage if the mission didn't go
exactly perfectly and of course there
was no need to reprogram it if that's
what happened so here we were out of
telemetry coverage and then they decided
to use the the limb abort guidance
system
to do that burn and drop the thing
without any knowledge of the guidance
software it took control away from the
guidance software gave it to the on
board line of work guidance system which
fired the descent stage separated and
did an asset stage burn and then they
handed the control back to the guidance
system well nobody had ever planned or
thought that that would happen in the
guidance system on our guidance system
on the limb knew that it was in the
descent configuration by then the
descent stage had been thrown off and so
the digital autopilot had this little
sporty vehicle when it was thought it
was controlling this massive thing and
so it was doing horrible limit cycles
and burning fuel like nobody ever saw
and they said what's going on well I
knew right away what was going on nobody
of course had asked MIT anything when
all this was happening they just knew
better and took over of course I thought
they didn't know better but I again sent
the information up that if they do this
heat soak thing that we had put in there
that the first thing it did was to check
agreement between the the bits that
indicated what stages were present and
the configuration the guidance system
thought and if it found a mismatch it
would correct the situation for the
guidance system and then pop out of this
program so it was a way to get the thing
back in sync with one uplink command and
when this was made known to the flight
director he said we can't do that
program we've never run it in our
practice simulations here at Mission
Control and here was this thing that we
can know we spend a lot of time putting
in there it was a second thing in the
flight software that couldn't or
wouldn't be used
Mission Control well the result was not
good and we took a lot of flack for them
I think a lot of it undeserved but I
think it really shook up the Mission
Control people who realized that their
abilities to handle things was much
lower than they thought in their ability
to understand and deal with the
possibilities of what would go wrong in
the flight computer and in the system
other than that was it completely
undeveloped and I think they went
through a lot of learning and made a lot
of changes that led to the success in
things like the lunar landing where
something really unexpected came up and
there were people there who were
confident enough or without some of
these blunders that happened I think
there would have been a much worse they
could ask you did you the clever things
that you had put in were they known to
the Mission Control as you saw in the
software festivals
well our contacts knew the difference
it wasn't our job and we didn't have
time to do anything that wasn't our job
we didn't have time to do things at work
I was working hours a week during Aaron
Cohen kept saying go down to Grumman and
talk to them win who's going to do the
configuration controlled by the state
Italy nine o'clock every night looking
at the changes to the listing to make
sure that the assembly was successful
music it was I never would have stopped
but it just we were you know when you
were down at there that was one of the
only launches I went to when I was at
the Cape at that time and when that
happened I would state telling the group
here last time that there was a lot of
finger-pointing that
occurred on this narrow window you're
talking about as to whether this was a
programming error or whether we were
programming exactly what the engine we
were we were programming that to the
characteristics of the engine that were
given to us from Grumman and there was a
lot of finger-pointing as to whose fault
it was and and of course Along Came doc
Draper who was down at the Cape but he'd
like to know what was going on so there
was this picture of this madhouse
room with a listing this big opened up
to page you know 179 or whatever it is
and somebody sticking doc Draper's nose
into these various assembly language
things trying to try to talk about how
this engine would cutoff points out
something else they didn't think of I
think it's worth saying I don't know if
206 was the first mission of this sort
but it was a first in him it may have
been where Houston had told us that they
not we were gonna be responsible for
what we call the erasable load which was
to stop yeah it's preloaded into the
erasable memory before launch so the
responsibility for the erasable load was
ostensibly with the guys down in Houston
well that was fine but for the simulator
we had to have a lot of stuff pre-loaded
into her a civil memory and there was
this piece of code called mr. clean
which would go clean out stuff and
preload all of these constants that we
thought would be fine for the erasable
to start with and the people could
override those and so forth but that's
what that thing did if I remember that
it was there for some reason
remember it was popular commercial on
the radio at the time it happened to fit
in these letters and so that's one
but it turned out Houston never touched
irreversible for at least for 206 and so
the stuff that we had in there for the
simulator which always worked in the
simulator and Roman ran the simulations
and we never heard I never heard
anything from Gro moments and sometimes
funny there but there was another sort
of one of these mismatches where we
never saw what Houston might have done
to the erasable / turns out they didn't
do anything but there were these
interface gaps that weren't local but
they were between geographic locations
that that went wrong and I think caused
people to shore up the defenses a little
bit on missions that came later but
without some of those mishaps I don't
know but that was a tremendous
disappointment to all of us busted our
tails on the 206 and it was never
possible to point a finger
I could never point a finger at anybody
I remember exactly where I was standing
when the person who was responsible for
the dips burn I'm not going to mention
his name but everybody here I think no
one told me there were restrictions on
that thing and so the number came
directly from him I didn't make it so it
wasn't something that we did just crazy
mishaps helped us a lot the accident of
course took three lives was way beyond a
heart and purview but the biggest effect
is I think without that accident we
never would have made the schedule and
maybe never would have made the land if
something else I remember about it it
was to have flown the flight program 204
yeah that program which we were forced
to release was just so lousy
so shuffle about it would have killed
him anyway
it was so cool I'm sort of a blessing
you can call it that that was ditched
and was never used and we went into the
blog too but it's an example of how I
mentioned before each program was
supposed to be an evolutionary step from
the one yeah this one had a crew another
one before it had no person if you don't
think that was utterly different acting
if it's huge other lay different and
then we had six weeks to turn it out
yeah very good
and of course nobody wanted to be the
one that caused the schedule to sleep
yep we were confident gremlin would make
the schedule slip
we just knew they'd never make it of
course they did which comes a lot a lot
of us by surprise a lot of good things
happen to I remember when we ordered the
first 360 Lyndon Johnson had just
ensured that IBM got a sole source
contract to supply for 360 75 s of
manned spacecraft Center and all the
other vendors were just completely up in
arms and IBM who was the only bidder
that could do this supposedly had to
supply a fifth computer because the four
computers didn't meet the spec since
birth it was a horrible situation and I
went to the guy I had to go to to say we
needed faster machine and we wanted to
put out a request for proposal and
approval to do that we could bids from
at least three vendors and I called him
up and I said well we've done our
proposal evaluation were ready to
proceed any problem on it and he said no
not anything at all he said who's the
winner of your proposal
I said IBM he said oh he said we're
gonna need a lot of justification for
that we spent about of months writing
down what we
they wanted to hear people's time if I
was a guy sort of saying why IBM was
chosen vendor so there were a certain
amount of politics in there that didn't
have anything to do with us but other
funny things happened I don't know if
this is used for not Houston wanted to
have an independent computer simulation
from one we had as a cross chamber and
so they assigned somebody to write a
simulator in the road of Fortran I think
not the computer but some other stuff
and I had personally modified our Mac
executive so that some things that we
needed to do and could be done by
runtime software in the Mac executive
that ran at runtime for Mac that
involved stealing some functions that I
knew nobody or thought nobody would ever
use like we had hyperbolic cosecant
function in in the language that I
didn't think anybody had ever used and
so if you put hyperbolic cosecant of
minus 1 in there or something it would
type on the console typewriter or
something and I got a look at the
listing of their independent simulators
written in Fortran and right there
that's a hyperbolic cosecant of minus 1
to 2 right on the console of a machine
there wasn't even one we used and
certainly not what you call an
independent simulation translator
or town without the slightest idea what
have you done here we are with a real
cross-check we did get there well I was
going to say had lost the thread senior
moment it happens almost continually
with me now after having gotten this
first IBM machine against all odds and
getting it installed and stealing it
from from somebody that we were doing
business with and George Miller called
him up and told him they were gonna have
to lose their machine it got very ugly
because they got really this company got
really angry with us for identifying
them as somebody who might give up a
machine and so forth it took us quite a
long time to get it in and installed and
and we were running lots of simulations
on there and a lot of other lab stuff as
well when we realized we just needed
more simulation time than there was on
one machine in a week so I went to Chris
Kraft and said we gotta have a second
machine it was absolutely astonishing
within six weeks that machine was
running in our place before it had taken
probably ten months and he just was able
to make things happen for us and for
everybody else in the project that
really gave it what it needed to succeed
and I think without influences like
Chris Kraft both inspirationally because
he really was a guy we all respected and
liked and without his cloud project
would have
not made it I mean there were just lots
of things that happened to come together
by the way he's written every recent
book has anybody read that it's like
seen him on TV and heard him on the
radio talking about it but I've never
had a chance to look at the book is
supposed to be pretty good but on Apollo
yeah the space program and issues and
everything very Frankton also written
gene Kranz his book that the volume of
timbal grams was actually published and
circulated I've never seen that evening
they have some here Malcolm sent his
packet to you guys right thank you
descending sanity wait after words it
must have been 91 or so I saw a little
tin delight in the metrics and urged him
to publishes Tindall grams him maybe
already had but if I didn't say so he
said why would anybody want to read this
I tried to sell him on the idea about -
you didn't further do it as far as I
know but I did read present they were
circulated another guy without which
things would have gone far differently
at Porsche right bill Tyndall helps
solve so many especially at houston's
down there Oh drag them all together and
beat enough heads found enough heads
together to to get agreement you it was
amazing how he did it without any just
by dint of his personality I'm not sure
he really was the guy the boss of any of
those people but when he said it I
remember before Bill the ill-fated dr.
Joe Shea that poor Joe that's why we
and joking he got the ax playing for a
lot of things that weren't his fault I
thought that he had a style about him in
conducting even those fast science that
were first article configuration
inspection it was Joe Shea sit like this
sure Red Sox fans
he didn't run an unassuming guy I was
kind of fun of him and you know look at
it from afar then he goes he was the
escape goat for you know in the in the
later stages of the program we talked a
lot about that personnel and the people
at MIT and the people that we got and
and so on and their closeness the latest
stages of the program it was a
determination that we didn't have enough
personnel and we needed we needed to run
this more like a an aerospace program
you might say and so it was actually an
effort to bring in contractor personnel
and I don't know how many were brought
in but quite a few a lot and vice and by
and large these people were very good
people and they and they were integrated
into into our efforts but it was just
another example of how something that
began relatively small and closed
started to get toward the end look like
a lot of other programs where you
brought in people you know
the different badges and different
management and so on and then you also
face that tried to parcel or apportion
them in intelligent ways I you know
either testing or try to get try to
create tasks that they could do that
were self-contained but in many cases
they weren't integrated into into groups
that have been IT personnel as well I
think that by and large that the lead
that we did that fairly successfully and
in the point software coop I think they
were taught they you couldn't even
remember that they were subcontractors
yeah Jo SAP Panero to run that large
team crack the whip on all had a bunch
of guys from see you see yeah yeah
Phyllis and I remember how many from hey
see but if J Sampson hadn't been in that
group languished right we did the 501
with J and the gang related or most of
it Romy Gilbert okay any interaction
between the instrumentation lab and the
rest of MIT is a teaching institution
undergrads or grad students well they're
MIT there was close interaction about
the time Apollo started because it
wasn't so big and it was closely tied
with the Aero department and the
instrumentation lab was part of MIT then
you remember the Faculty Club athletic
and so on like Lincoln lab I don't know
maybe Lincoln lab still is but then at
some point due to the Vietnam protests
the lab split off I don't remember
early 70s
when that happened and became less
connected well it was there was
connections there were students you
always had research assistants that were
around I mean people like me who did
that twice I mean it went from employee
to and then became a student and got a
master's and then became a student got a
PhD and so on but there were other stood
there were always students around some
of them turned into astronauts like Buzz
Aldrin and I think ed Mitchell and some
others that were that were in the in the
Aero department at one time up Dave
Scott I think so
Lisa turned out to be students of dick
bat and I mean he and they all wanted to
know something about guidance and
control and and I think probably
students and Wally van de Velde as as
well so there was a a connection into it
although I don't think that the people
any of the people other than these
students that I mentioned I don't think
that the employees thought of themselves
as in any way as academics of any kind I
mean they were they were were in working
engineers in a laboratory associated
with MIT and there was some vague let's
say organizational connection of up
above that certain MIT policies would
flow down whether it was retirement
benefits or health benefits and other
things of that nature library cards and
going to the fact cloning the Faculty
Club things of that nature that that
meant that you had one big difference in
the laboratory that as opposed to some
other laboratories like
I'm not sure about the radiation lab but
I know with respect to Lincoln land
Lincoln at that time was a line item
laboratory in the Air Force so they got
there the F was had a budget and they
say there's a budget of a million
laboratories and did all that work under
this budget item and the invitation
laboratory didn't have any angel in that
sense and they had to scrounge around
and do their own marketing and find work
and so on and of course Draper who got
this huge sole-source contract into
Apollo which was magnificent but
basically the lab was not a kept lab
they had to do they had to get out there
in the world and finally find that
business and that was a big distinction
between that this laboratory and some of
the other MIT labs I think the thing
like that dan is referring to is that
during the Vietnam War there were
tremendous student gatherers campus here
and all kinds of protests of it I I
think I had just left the lab and I
can't remember what the essence of what
they were protesting at the lab I think
I was for a little ballistic missile
it's just military defense Contract they
had no place in that lab you know so you
had the instrumentation laboratories
yeah this whole section with Apollo you
might say but there are other sections
of the lab that we're doing inertial
guidance work for ballistic missiles and
so on and there and we heard stories of
them having you know barriers across the
doors and bolts and this and that and
pressure on to divest the laboratory
from there from the school and
eventually some some accommodation was
made with respect to the organizational
structure all of us were in one building
right around the corner here in
Cambridge Parkway we weren't over the
main MIT we were down where Dartz Lotus
what Lotus wasn't there then a bunch of
warehouses
right next to the hotel what's that so
that's that was a company I really
examine this relative right before of
course the paolo didn't start in there
we sort of gathered into that building
we started in other places see the lab
had I don't know that was w6 right seven
some beef 1106 was way down Vassar
Street and then there was one two three
four and five and they had a garage and
you had an old shoe polish building and
so on and and Apollo began in these
other buildings with various groups of
people here and a few people there and
so on but I can't remember the exact
date when everybody was I don't know
they have the big computers down there
in the first floor dick baton in the
corner and all of it I don't did when I
went to work the dick he was in w1 near
that elevator shaft that was him w1 and
so yeah so it must have been for the 656
T - yeah 1962 or so that everybody was
gathered and brought into this into this
one building what and he had things on a
roof - didn't you have a sextant than
something on the on the roof of this
building that did star sirens when we
all moved to the second floors when you
had the project organization and all of
that we took over all a second floor but
I thought that some of the nevins or
John Dolan or somebody I had optical
equipment a lot of it was but they had
to think under that you can look at them
they had that thing you sat down up
there dr. Draper's toy yeah anyway
there's there's quite a time in there
starting in the early 60s and escalated
as you got close
closer to each flight and I mean Alex
did the first one 201 I don't remember
the suit closes after the first few were
all unmanned and I don't even remember
the two one with the guy I think - it -
the first I - OH - I mean yeah right
- old one was just open-ended last
question probably but you know you'd
have any international contact did you
go abroad Europe whatever was anybody
interested from abroad and what you were
doing
I'm sure there was great interest but I
can't recall wasn't like Space Lab you
know way who where I did some work on
space level you had a real international
group that was that you were nobody in
the world was doing much yet and it's
always all pretty early and there were
people individuals interested but there
wasn't any institutional interest the
diary that it was huge popular interest
right is that in a paper in Paris at a
conference on a theory that had come out
of the Apollo project it was part of the
part of our organization sent us there
so in that way but it wasn't really what
we did in Apollo was what came as a
result of it
well the interested very interested I
just can't read my mind
I was about the mid seventies all right
um you know early 70s early something in
other words but it was still part of the
Apollo group
the colloquium program programación
probe colloquium or something in Paris
mostly academics but yeah there was a
lot of interest but it was mostly
academics not application types no
during a Paulo most of our trips were to
Houston or for those of us that dealt
with Rockwell out to Rockwell or it was
all the business but some of us either
shocked I was shocked when I first made
a trip to North American and you know we
had I don't know where you have the the
Cambridge scene here you know everybody
has his own office and building sort of
quiet and you look out the window he
might see the river and watch the
plane's take off yeah what's plans take
well that was my fate and then you you
went made these business trips out to
North America but you were faced with
was this three block long open hangar
you know with diagonals how many people
in their hangar and telephones of
bringing in tango is the father age of
the building flossed Ennis alrighty good
so I mean it doesn't mean the contrast
you you wondered you know how anybody
got any work done and yeah
the the contrast between what what we
used to think of as the aerospace
industry and the the norm of how people
worked in this aerospace industry versus
the norm of what we were doing at MIT
was like night and day I mean it was
just different world right there were
metal vendors and they wanted to build
ten thousand more airplanes if we told
them all I mean like graduate students
office right at MIT you walk in there I
came from the meteorology department I
felt like it was part of the same
environment it was not like a big
corporation out outside of MIT
it was interesting in the early years to
me to find that MIT people we were never
instrumentation allowed people were
always MIT people from reason although
we had this local environment of our own
when we went up to to a North American
we found that we were the communication
means between parts of North American
that we interfaced with that didn't talk
to each other and often we were the ones
that told them things that their own
management perhaps should have told
about they were really glad to know and
we've served it very useful if
inadvertent function that way
interesting you say that because the
glue that Alex was talking about
I put when we put together the different
powered flight and navigation everything
we found that we were a communication
vehicle that the entire mission software
for the different groups that were being
interfaced as well and that's how we
learned about what we didn't really know
what was inside the bike or at least I
was less familiar than you inside the
black boxes but we really knew how they
all tied together one more thing you
probably should say about this working
at the lab which was MIT we were in a
very privileged position we got to see
and talk to not only all the astronauts
everybody at the NASA all over the place
I mean Verner von Braun would come and
visit and I can remember
giving lectures on what we're doing and
so forth with all those people we got to
talk to as a small sort of elite
organization and when the flights were
going off the Apollo flights we've tied
in very closely on those headsets and
boxes I can remember one flight I don't
remember what and who I was talking with
it Houston might have been jack guy and
I said it was a problem we had and I
said I think we need an erasable dump
will you get one within 30 seconds on
the main cop commander Kove Capcom water
to the astronauts MIT wants a dump while
you do it something or other
and it was always MIT wants this and
that and so I felt anything we did was
going to get there and back very quickly
that might have been the time we were
worried about the erasable being messed
up I think I also thought some people
attributed sort of a pedestal standing
to us that maybe one thing that happened
oh that I so vividly recalled was it was
near the end of that there was a landing
on the moon and it was successful and
they were and I mean the program either
was yeah was just after that landing or
it could have been just before word we
used to go to these dinners at lock
overs and I don't know how many where I
went to maybe and Draper was very
expansive about this and he want to get
you know all those people there and he'd
have to always have some astronauts and
they were good that was kind of fun and
so I remember this dinner and I was
sitting next to Frank Borman and we were
eating dinner and Frank Borman somewhere
in the conversation he felt that the
people at MIT were all sort of geniuses
and and we were all you know just these
I mean almost like everybody was a guru
and everybody was a genius and I and
then he said to me something like you
guys have in mind - you idiot you ought
to get out of this program now he said
this program is nothing but it's going
to be just grinding it out he said
there's not gonna be anything more of
interest there's nothing more that you
guys can do you ought to go out and do
something bigger and more interesting
that was all right yeah we we did have a
good position but also there were so
many of the astronauts that have prior
previous connections at MIT that we
weren't
poked fun at too much we had some inside
track I might tell you just as a closing
comment for me is that dick batten has
asked they asked me last year to be a
guest lecturer at one of his sessions he
he runs a Freshman Seminar on Apollo and
he has these kids and kids come in and
last year he had Harrison Schmitt beside
his name the astronaut and he had a
number of other people and I was there
he's trying to get Don Isles to come in
and he it's really sort of a tomorrow I
only did it once and and so what you do
is you're talking to these kids who are
about 18 years old a date really know
almost nothing zero I mean whatever they
know they know from television I'm a
cartoonist maybe they ran something or
they know nothing but it is interesting
the level of interest that they have in
the program and usually a certain
percentage of them like four out of
eight or five out of ten all have they
all want to be astronauts that's one of
the things that drives them because I
you know you wonder why this person as a
freshman takes this Freshman Seminar
with dick batten on a call from you know
30 years ago but they it is interesting
of course dick loves and I did bring in
some artifacts you know this is a
program with thicknesses of this this is
life and most of it is just getting up
to a blackboard and drawing a few stick
figures and telling them a little bit
about how you get how we got to the moon
and something about the computer and
each person has something else to say of
course I'm sure that Harrison Schmitt
here in the whole astronaut viewpoint it
really it is remarkable for these kids
have this connection through dick baton
to this world because it's something
that that very few people very few high
school students a very few freshman
college could have an opening to to and
to have these individuals appear in
front of them and just say you know he
just loves it yes it's something I felt
I know coming from your friends and
relatives there the incredible intensive
that interest in Apollo what happened I
often feel like since I was in it I
haven't done my bit in satisfying some
of their yearning for information and
contact with this glamorous world and
that's just sort of a popular reaction
has nothing to do with military academia
this is or anything think the men in the
street use the American Apollo program
is just I think an incredible
achievement if it ever really happened
they do you know the websites that we're
working on you know one of its functions
would be after provide a window into the
history of that program for students
general audience who might be interested
in that post the basis in documents but
also the human subjective perspective on
this events so we could thank you all
very much
your job is gonna be a severe one in
terms of getting people young people now
interested in things that by comparison
with today's technology are so so pretty
why would anybody want to look back and
stuff
oh machine that had a three bit opcode I
just bought the Microsoft Flight
Simulator 2 mm and it says you need to
have 635 megabytes of disk space
available operating system that comes
out this [ __ ] says what I can do is
why would they care about a 36 K word
machine and the problems just so
completely removed from today's problem
and I think this sort of being less I
mean it can be knitted into today but
you have along with your comment is I
think that in looking around in the
software problems
today that there they still have the
same problems that they had yesterday
and I think that many of the things that
we learned and that evolved lessons
learned up can still be learned today
I think software in fact it's worse in
many ways now it's done in a more
primitive way now than it was back
because the resources are a limitless
people just don't yeah don't try so I
think we could go back and learn a lot
and a lot of what has evolved from that
so if we can then some of us are in
trouble it's just progression of
machines getting bigger and better yeah
and also evolution of human skill how
you thing right right model in wrestling
exactly so and some of those skills in
the 60s might have been some very viable
that is not really use now sometimes we
go go back to the very foundations the
very core and learn from what we might
have thrown away the other thing is that
if people even though they can hold a
handheld GPS in their hand they're still
interested in how people did things with
a sextant and a watch or not even a
watch a corner or a disky or a Biscay
which I could sometimes call apartments
yeah maybe we should have a simulator of
a disc a on the website so you can
actually press yeah yes that would be
great then you can call up all the
programs get Jeff's emulator gone again
you can have your verbs and nouns all
right thank you very much I will be able
to add shell as soon as we have a
transcript I will send all of you for
Corrections and you know Oh an old man a
copy of the transcript from the prior
meeting so I can know all right yeah